welcome to the show today guys i want to
let you know that i have some tour dates
if you want to see me in live in the
live space visual
real time they call it irl
jacksonville florida february 2nd i'll
be there saint petersburg florida
february 3rd
orlando florida february 5th
lafayette indiana february 24th rockford
illinois february 25th chicago illinois
february 26th
tulsa oklahoma oh that's sold out now
may 6. we may add one there and then los
angeles california at the wilton may 7th
that is all return of the rat tour you
can grab those tickets or until now
theovonne.com
tour
today's guests are uh two men
who have um
who are from another country
and they left their country
i'm not sure why exactly but
but that's what they did and uh i'm
we're very happy to have them here today
they are one of the most uh one of the
greatest
uh selling artists of all time
of modern time of all
bc or ace aad
uh mr robbie williams and
comedian
mark hayes
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah what's the most fancy thing ever
that you bought for yourself
what's the most fancy thing that i ever
bought for myself um
what a really big house
[Laughter]
really really big house
like because i i had i had a place
that i would say was like quite humble
for me yeah looking back
yeah and that was like a mansion yeah
it's like a mansion in beverly hills in
a gated community and it was but
then i just was like i want to put my
foot down on this and out on
bought a place in beverly hills it's 20
acres
yeah that you have right now yeah oh 28
20 acres thirty rich dogs
because thirty thousand square foot
no way yeah with that's 20 acres jesus
yeah
dude you could ha
are there rooms that you haven't been in
in months
i've got
27 toilets
that's unreal isn't it yeah
but let me tell you the thinking
okay sorry so the thinking is this let
me push this back
[Laughter]
so you make some money
yeah and then you want to keep that
money right and then you want to do
things that you understand and i don't
understand much
so
i jen you you know i i and
you've got all these stocks and shares
and investments that you can make i
don't understand them right what do i
understand i understand bricks and
mortar right so if i have some bricks
and mortar
and the stock market and everything goes
to hell in a handbasket
it still exists the bricks and mortar
will be there so i took the money out of
the investments and invested it into
bricks and mortar yeah and bought this
place 20 acres 30 000 square foot blah
blah blah blah blah and you just like ah
i did a grown-up thing i did a grown-up
thing yeah and you i'm really proud of
myself and then you go right okay
what you don't take into consideration
is 20 acres needs tending in beverly
hills oh yeah so you need two gardeners
and then that's where i come in and yeah
hold on hold on hold on though so then
you've got your
insurance for the house so the insurance
on the house because of the fires is 700
grand
wait so the insurance because of fires
it's 700 grand a year yeah worse
seriously yeah and then you have your
house tax thing each year which is 400
000.
so basically what you don't take into
consideration when you're buying bricks
or more especially in california is that
okay so you need two gardeners
three housekeepers a house manager wow i
have security oh yeah two nannies
for you yeah
just for me yeah so then what so
basically what i'm saying is you can't
win anyway because you know the the the
the tax of actually the like the life
tax right the head tax right of having a
property that big
you just can't enjoy it
you come down off the mic a little sorry
it's good you come downstairs and you
see 11 cars parked in your car park
outside and they all work at yours wow
so
you know you i'm basically wandering
around
a super yacht yeah on land oh so it's
sort of like dre it's like a super yacht
drain
but on land why because you constantly
just see the money going by you mean
yeah
yeah you just see i walk down and
everything looks like an expense kind of
well i walk into the kitchen today and
there is one two three four five six
seven eight people
and none of them are my family
[Laughter]
do you know to me and they're they're
all doing good job for me
and so i i it's just like you know like
an
old taxi where you just sort of like
watching the
the cash go up and up oh yeah even
earlier when i walked in how many people
were like cooking food there was eight
people in the kitchen
not including us and and the four kids
yeah that's always like it feels homely
here yeah there's so many people and
like the food was cooking oh that's nice
so my big expense yeah is on people that
work for me right i i'm not a big um
i'm not a big sort of
needless if for example if i want a like
bling watch i'm like love hip hop i want
to blink watch too i then get in touch
with the company and see what i can do
for the company to get the watch for
free oh i see so you like to see you
like to save money in some some senses
uh i don't know what that is that's what
we
anyway back to what we were talking on
the way in that's the level of money i'm
willing to spend on a studio is one
where you have to hear something in the
distance every day
anxiety so what's going on
i don't know man i think i just get
overwhelmed i don't like being like a
boss i don't like having like once
comedy kind of started to turn more also
into podcasting you have to like
you know help get things done and make
sure that everything runs smoothly and
it just becomes
a bit like i think it just starts to
exhaust me i i don't get to be as
creative you know so when i'm listening
to you say that you have help and people
are helping you
i'm like that really perks my ears up
because i'm like but then but then you
just have another level of problems
before you got anxiety about being the
boss you're anxious about something else
yeah
so you just you're just swapping
problems yeah
yeah yeah
but mine sounds like a better problem
than you it does yeah yeah there's a
fountain out front of it yeah
but
my problem does feel better than yours
yeah
who's got better problems that would be
almost a great game show it's just like
somebody's like i've got down syndrome
and somebody else is like i've got
anxiety
and people vote in the crowd i'd be like
have diarrhea
yeah yeah yeah i i got a paper cut
i chafed a nipple
but here do you know when you wore a
sharp shirt
there was no anxiety when you were
growing up was there yeah was it or not
and no you didn't know it was anxiety
basically you just on high alert all of
the time because i'm i'm from
not a lot of money i mean i'm from a
rough area like billy elliot like
exactly like billy elliot yeah
i love that movie so there's no anxiety
but like i thought
that when i was growing up i had like a
psychic ability
to know that there was going to be
trouble that was i thought that it was
like i've got this inbuilt
radar that detects
trouble but actually what it is is
you're around sociopaths and psychopaths
yeah so you're actually scared all of
the time
yeah all
of the time
just living in fear all of the time and
like my wife who's from beverly hills
yeah
she's had an ensuite all of her life oh
i'm from a place where we had a bath on
sunday and i was a third in the bath
afternoon i'm third in the water huh
you're collecting yeah you're freaking
collecting coins at that point
my grandma right my grandma first in
didn't have a indoor toilet until 1983.
wow yeah just open the alley out in the
yard wow yeah it's almost hot she could
she could have an only fans now
that's what's crazy yeah is that now
that so but that's so your grandma's
toilet
somebody would pay for it i'm sure colin
or jake one of these guys would frickin
chip in on it
i've seen some pretty dark stuff i'm
sure
um but yeah so what we were so
a lot of fear so you always felt fear
because one of my first feelings that i
ever remember in the whole world is
being afraid
yeah
my my first memory is lucid dreaming
that i could fly
oh damn and then i woke up and nearly
threw myself down the stairs
like that yeah but i i because i was
born in a pub
yeah yeah so like
we lived in a pub for my first four
years so i know that my first memory i
must have been three or under
and it was lucid dreaming who are you
who am i yeah because i i've just been
doing a load of talking and you're
we're just sitting here with robbie
williams and mark hayes i mean we'll
we'll do an intro in the beginning too
um and you guys are mates and you guys
are from another country oh yeah ireland
england two separate countries two
separate countries yeah same to
americans yeah yeah to us i think it
does run together you know
i feel like america is getting so weird
people are starting to go back i've been
seeing like mayflowers and stuff ads on
the internet for like the new mayflower
and it's heading back across
to england i think people are the
titanic is going home
yeah i think people are willing to take
on an iceberg just to maybe change the
scope of things here's the thing though
i think america is so good no matter how
mental it gets
will still come yeah yeah
because you're just like you just see
baywatch or you see like mtv
oh yeah i want that yeah you see one
warm tid on a shelf yeah and you're just
like oh this is better than a cold test
yeah
i've lived in la for 21 years
and i i don't know if you have this with
la or you
have this at all but like every five
years i'll try and leave l.a
something will happen where i'll just
get pissed off and there'll be like a a
bunch of things or a bunch of people
where i'm just like you've
really let me down in only a way that
people in los angeles can let me then oh
yeah that's true and then i go no no i
am leaving
and then i get on the plane and i take
all the dogs and the children
and my clothes and i land in england and
i got i'd need to get back this is [ __ ]
have you heard that happen all the time
have you every time i've done it i've
done it four times really yeah like i
bought a house in the countryside in
england right i bought this it's a
castle isn't it yeah bought this place
in the countryside in england and like
this is our forever home wife
and we are living here now and we leave
those people destiny people in los
angeles and the children will grow here
and we'll provide memories and i better
not tell her that i hate it and i want
to move back second night
really second night of buying the house
i was like i don't like it was that
really was it the english anxiety coming
in because i could that in ireland if i
went home and like sat in my couch i'm
like oh
this is where like i was trying to get
away from
yeah
but do you think it's because something
feels like
simpler there does it feel like not
like what are some of the feelings that
would make you think that it's is it too
quiet is it too
simple is it too
old-fashioned like is there things that
make you think like i i think in ireland
it feels a bit restricted whereas in l.a
like anything could happen
there's opportunity yeah yeah
and like
sometimes it obviously does yeah most of
the time obviously it doesn't yeah yeah
but in los angeles you just think i am
going i'm walking around the corner and
adam sandler is going to go we should do
it
about your life where i play you and i'm
like yeah adam sandler that should
happen it's delusional that everyone of
our levels yeah
yeah there's a guy with spiderman
screaming at people he's like i think it
used to be more like that was a
possibility though you know i think it
used to i i don't or that used to be
certainly a dream do you think that's
still i think maybe
in our age that was a dream like yeah i
could walk down the street and like eric
estrada's going to walk up or frickin uh
you know i'm trying to think of somebody
else
and his wife i think he's deaf i don't
even know that which makes the whole
incredible hulk way more messed up i
think dude painting
in 21 years of living here the only
thing that has actually happened like
that where somebody walks up to you and
offers you something was i was at
galleria 16 in the valley and i was
offered the chance
to be the bachelor no yeah yeah yeah you
know who you are i don't know yeah i
didn't have that look yeah maybe maybe
it was a while ago but like the only
thing that's ever happened was sort of
like you could be the bachelor yeah yeah
i think a lot that that kind of took
over where like it was like reality
shows people could get like would you be
the bachelor
no
no why
i just would have i think i'd have uh
that's a good question why i couldn't be
the bachelor man i think i would just be
kind of scared i would just be
i don't know i'd be flirting with the
chicks but then like
i'd be trying to perv out at night
probably and like
sneak around or something
i don't know i'd probably get busted
masturbate you know it's something bad
something that make me seem a little bit
strange i think
your true self comes out yeah i think my
true self i think my true self can't
help but come out okay let's let's pitch
that show okay but let's pitch it where
it's called something else now but it's
the same as the bachelor book
okay
what streaming service is it on or what
tv channel is it on what's it called oh
the perv the perv
maybe called uh
who's tom thumb isn't it a famous
character tom thumb
it's yeah it's easily a fairy tale or
something maybe like a peeping tom
something for peeping toms but where
they're like doing well
maybe maybe you wouldn't be maybe you'd
be the is it chris hanson oh yeah maybe
you'd be the presenter of that oh yeah
and then you wouldn't have to be you
wouldn't have to be the perf yeah yeah i
could be like the perv wrangler the perv
yeah i'd be the poor i'd make a good
prank
straight after this ted's around us hop
in the car we'll go pitch it
here we come this is sarandos back to
the england thing yeah take some
explaining so you get over there so this
is what happens for me okay right so um
at one point in my life i was
ridiculously famous right in a country
that you haven't been to right and like
but ridiculously like michael jackson
style famous right and how old was he
how old was i yeah um i became famous
when i was 17. oh man
yeah i i joined a boy band when i was
16. the boy band took off right and then
when i was 21 i left and then i had a
solo career
and sold 80 million albums
hold the t hold the record for the most
tickets sold in a day for a tour and
blah blah blah blah and all of that
business
so
this meets with i'm sober right i'm a
sober guy right
but this meets with depression
and anxiety
and mental illness
and extreme fame and extreme success
yeah
and i came to america
to
promote an album
and i'm over here promoting this album
i'm in like milwaukee and i'm doing a
radio station to eight people it's seven
o'clock in the morning yeah and like i
already have like millions in the bank
and a huge following
and like i'm in milwaukee and i'm
depressed and i'm anxious and there's a
guy going gee robbie that was a great
performance i hope we can uh play your
record and i i'm
it's seven o'clock in the [ __ ]
morning
what's this hope i can play your record
shoot yeah
and so i'm going around america doing
all of this stuff and i'm like going and
gone so
all of this fame's making me
anxious and depressed
and if i go to america i'm famous in
papua new guinea if i'm famous in
america right
oh so this realization is happening as
i'm traveling through america trying to
break america and then i can remember
doing like a rock the vote performance
in new york
like and i've i've never voted in my
life
and i'm just like trying to tell the
kids to vote
and i'm like this is this is this is not
authentic
and then i'm like hang on what am i
doing here why am i trying to break this
why don't i go and live there
live in an anonymity
and then
have a nice life so the pair the the the
grown-up driving the car made a decision
to not promote in america not do
anything so 21 years ago i moved here
and turned everything down i was offered
in the states like the bachelor like the
bachelor yeah
so basically this is what happens is
that i live in anonymity here and i
really really enjoy that wow then i
tried to move back to my home country
and remember that i have no anonymity
there and that makes me feel anxious and
depressed wow and then i moved back to
los angeles so that's basically what
happens you know keeping things fresh is
uh it's tantamount
it's paramount
it's important um
it's one of the premier things and i
have trouble keeping things fresh you
know i'm not a real i'm not that fresh
man
i'm not that fresh if you look at the in
the crisper drawer in my house you're
not gonna there's nothing in there
you know i i don't really have that much
uh
that much that's fresh in my world
but who does is peloton
one peloton that's right
they've got the bike the bike plus
but they're freshening things up for the
new year they've got boxing
new music artists
series
new daily workout varieties
it's easy to stick to your goals when
you
freshen them up
when you spray a little bit of that br
imagine it's taking your gold one of
your goals and opening its dang mouth
and just spraying a mint
breath mint in there
damn
beautiful
peloton has a workout for every goal
every day every mood
de-stressed from a long day with 30
minutes of strength 20 minutes of cardio
do a quick 15-minute total body workout
if that's all you have time for stay
motivated while having fun with bike
workouts yoga meditation dance cardio
and more for a limited time try the
peloton app free for two months then
just 12.99 after
per month
new members only visit onepeloton.com
app to learn more that's two months free
at o n e
p e l o t o n dot com
all for expires 1 31 22 terms apply
this podcast is sponsored by better help
you know uh
man i've had a lot of unmanageability in
my brain
um
and then it's in my life
you know what starts upstairs in my head
ends
downstairs in my life
and so i've got to manage that
i've been spending time recently to take
more advantage of getting well
betterhelp can do that for you
they will assess your needs and match
you with a licensed professional
therapist
they're not joking around
they don't want to waste your time
you'll get thoughtful responses
the services available for clients
worldwide
it is committed to facilitating better
help is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches
get some help and get a therapist you
can talk to them you can video skype
with them journaling
you could send out probably a homing
pigeon and come back with them
you're doing good it'll say
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's better h-e-l-p
dot com slash theo join the over 2
million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health special offer for this past
weekend listeners get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
[Music]
theo this spot this podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp that's insane what a crazy
that that that los angeles would be a
place that you would come for comfort i
feel like you know yeah but it's
interesting
did um
a lot of rappers they say that they
don't like to live in their hometown
because people will kill him you know
like a lot of like like little boosie
was in here and he said he doesn't like
to live in uh in louisiana because
people will kill him there because they
get jealous and stuff like that is there
a lot of that kind of stuff in england
like i've never i've never ever said
this but yeah i had a contract out of me
to kill me no way yeah jesus never said
it publicly ever wow
did you put it off yourself
was it pr yeah yeah
no is it still out no does it go away
went away jesus what happened i have
friends
damn yeah i have friends
but like you know that that stuff sort
of
is the unseen stuff that happens when
you become famous because you were
insanely yeah being insanely famous i
can't even fathom you know like i've
been over to like like i've spent time
around justin bieber that kind of stuff
is insane you know to see
um some of these ufc guys it gets pretty
insane really yeah but i can't because
did you feel like you needed to escape
then or did you feel like you were just
going
did you feel like you were leaving
england like you wanted to leave or do
you feel like you you wanted to go
somewhere else if that makes any sense
well there's that there's that
there's like a few levels
of fame and what it does to you and the
the first one is [ __ ] and there's a
couple more i can't remember but the
fourth one is like acceptance
you know you sort of rally against this
your privacy being taken away from you
and you you rally against it by um
trying to be normal and try to be normal
but also i'm going to be small so you
don't beat me up i'm a [ __ ]
don't hurt me and i'm going to go to all
the normal places i can't go because
people want to kill me
and but it takes a while to get to
acceptance
you can't do it yeah and and did you go
to the shop in england
yeah i i
i i could with my coved mask on oh yeah
but you couldn't just like walk down the
street and pop in no
really yeah
with a car is like oh [ __ ]
would you
you know it's like i have anxiety
and i don't like meeting strangers
but like strangers want to meet me yeah
and i feel really uncomfortable about it
and it's like thinking about it now
actually gives me anxiety
so it's like it's a trigger it's like
and also you've got to be the mayor of
the best town that anybody's ever
visited or else people go he's one of
those famous people that are a dick oh
yeah you got to be the nicest guy every
time the nicest and actually it's hard i
i i hate having my picture taken oh i
[ __ ] hate it i hate it with my wife
oh yeah like she does instagram and i'm
just like the [ __ ] off
like the the act of having a picture
taken makes me go
ugh
for whatever reason that is probably
because so much use in the chinese
believe this and i don't really even
believe in the chinese a lot of times
but i believe that it takes your soul
yeah it's not the chat i thought it was
like the indians otherwise the indians
yeah i think that's a made-up well the
chinese borrowed it because i remember
i was in china one time trying to take a
picture of somebody and they're like
they come up and try to cover the camera
yeah they don't want because it like
they said like it captures a little bit
of you so i think it could make sense
that after someone has been so like
and i don't want to use the term
exploited but you
you know so much of your image and your
voice and everything is used for
uh
artwork or ambiance or
transaction or whatever that something's
got to leave out of your spirit it seems
like it seemed like it would do you feel
that at all did you ever
well that it takes a bit your soul yeah
maybe subconsciously that's what it is
that makes me feel anxious about it but
the the what happens in the process is
this is a i'm a chronic people-pleaser
too yeah it's like i want you to think
that i'm the nicest person that you've
ever met because if you don't and you go
away having a bad
time having met me i'll feel really
awful but also at the same time
but also at the same time it's like i
don't want you to have any time with me
at all
so i i
what i do is i become agrophobic but
like happily agrophobic and what is that
agrophobic not like crops or something
huh
agrophobic is that where you're scared
i'm talking about no it's way
that's agriculture agrophobic is like
where you're scared of going outside oh
but i'm not scared of going outside i
just don't want to yeah so i but it's
either but i even i do it also here in
los angeles where i'm not known
is that i'm not bothered to go outside
yeah i've been outside
i've been outside i've been outside
one thing if it gets interesting i think
and if you don't have a bad time first
of all go see one of mark's shows
that'll definitely
put you
[ __ ]
yeah you'll need to call a janitor to
help you uh
but it's interesting that one of the
things that happens is you have
with people you have the same
interaction over and over again that it
gets to be not mundane because each
person is
you know they're
a new soul and you're you know there's
but it becomes there does become a
repetition to it and sometimes i think
as somebody that's creative repetition
isn't something that makes you feel
comfortable
maybe or that you're like attracted to
kind of so i think sometimes that can be
a little bit strange does that make any
sense uh well there's there is a
repetition but there's also you being an
introvert doing an extrovert job yeah
my job is to be an extrovert but
actually why i was taking all of those
drugs is to make me feel okay because
i'm an introvert yeah is i i
want to be the life and soul of the
party
uh and i also want to have
things in common with everybody and you
know but i
haven't because actually what i want to
do is just stay in my bedroom all day
yeah it's crazy that being on stage is
the only time probably you get to do
both
yeah
well have you got kids i don't have no
kids man have you managed that i don't
know i just think i can i'm i'm not that
good at sex i'm not like a pre like if
somebody were picking people for
basketball first but it was for sex
they'd be like you know i'd be the guy
at the end that's like hey what about me
you know but i think i just haven't
really um
i don't know i think i'm old i'm 41 i'm
40 i'm 40.
you look that up i'm 41.
i'm 40 or 41.
so what do you think's gonna i mean i
want to have a i need to have a family
so i'm trying to get some help right now
for like i got a lot of commitment
issues 41 there you go bam
so um did you go to therapy
yeah so i'll go to therapy at 5 p.m
tomorrow and i'm thinking about going
away next month doing like a
couple of week or month men's retreat
somewhere to work on like intimacy
issues i just have a lot of like
commitment i just really have a tough
time committing just [ __ ] do it yeah
i like your attitude no but i'm on the
other side talk to us
yeah this guy is the worst yeah but he's
so unconscious yeah oh he is unconscious
he's completely and utterly unconscious
yeah it's like he you've you've stripped
away all of your stuff
you're sober right yeah okay so you're a
sober guy you don't get the joy of being
unconscious you you you see your
problems and you go i've got to deal
with that he's dealing with nothing no
no he's not it's great
yeah he's in the hov lane he has nobody
in the car with him yeah and he's not
even in a car he's moving backwards yeah
he's moving backwards yeah
he's moving backwards and he's walking
backwards i enjoy it he does that's the
thing because yeah i'm just thinking
it's better to be unconscious oh he's
like a hot dumb girl trapped in a daft
man over here
feeling away man and i say that lovingly
bud
i say i say that lovingly too i say that
with like
pangs of jealousy yeah
yeah
oh yeah to be just happy and just he's
the happiest guy i call him sometimes
just to get happiness out of him
he sometimes he he told me funny thing
he goes the more i get to know you the
sadder it is
but like
like
you're in that
predicament where it's like it's bad
but it's not bad enough not bad enough
for a minute i don't know if it ever
will be that's it it just stays above
the zone yeah cause like mine is sort of
like you know break out in handcuffs
lock me up really oh yeah lose wife lose
kids lose jobs lose everything oh yeah i
wouldn't have that you need to get
famous so bad things can happen
oh it would be bad for him it really
would yeah like he hasn't got a [ __ ]
clue he would be busted immediately yeah
so you just need you need a bit of fame
yeah you actually just stay where you
are you're good
yeah yeah yeah right in the zone oh
you're in a perfect spot you're always
having fun he loves chasing the ladies
and the ladies love them somehow you
know yeah they really do it's charm i
think it's good looks
mostly good looks it's charm chomp chomp
chomp what's that pete davidson thing
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's probably good
here
he looks like pete moss davidson you
know
from culture club
bringing peace moss can you bring it up
p-e-a-t m-o-s-s
there you are
yeah he's like pete moss davidson it's
just an actual yeah there you go look at
that preserved forest moss that's him
right there that's my hair get a good
look at him yep
yep
that's him
is that the reference that you were
going for yeah
yeah just kind of a damaged phone
oh i think that all these compliments
yeah
yeah sometimes i think um
did you have like a lot of problems with
like uh
like commitment and stuff like that was
it hard for you to get a wife i mean i'm
sure it was easy because okay so
it was genuinely
the biggest leap of faith
to ever make wow
and i could have missed it and it was a
slide indoors moment
and
you you may have missed
the perfect person for you it's two
layers
no you stay away well here's okay he
does
okay so here's the thing right yeah i
mean i'm anxious i'm depressed
i can't keep my penis in my pants yeah
um i can't look after myself
how the hell am i going to turn up and
be a decent human being for another
person right exactly i'm listening
yeah yeah okay so that's that's what i
was thinking it's like
how i can't do this i can't be the
person that i want to be or the person
that you need me to be so i'm not going
to bother right
as it happens
17 years later four kids later i am that
guy and i was that guy
and i was given the i gave myself the
opportunity to be that guy
my beautiful wife gave me the
opportunity to be that guy and believed
in me but did you just say one day i'm
that guy did you go to like therapy did
you do there things you did that helped
you get there it's like giving up
drinking or giving up drugs yeah it
genuinely is one day at a time 17 years
worth of days later with my wife wow i'm
in a monogamous relationship with
somebody that i really like who's really
cool really great to look at really
smart and really creative
and
i you are you can be that guy
yeah me too you can't
[Laughter]
you can't you're so far away from being
that guy
yeah it does sound like a big leap of
faith yeah oh it's the biggest because
not only that
she gets half if i'm not that guy
that's what i was going to say because
then you i like to project in the future
and be like ah yeah but if it doesn't
work [ __ ] it don't don't leap
but you're more you if your wife can't
that's gotta be crazy to go to bed at
night and know if your wife kills you
she's coming up roses yeah
i don't i don't even think about that
bit but
at the start it was just like there was
when you asked when you said i mean
you're going to be my girlfriend were
you serious about it when you said it to
her no i didn't
i didn't say that i broke up with her
three times
yeah like the and like the first two
first three the three times that i broke
up with it she didn't even know
she went back to a house and then like a
flatbed truck turned up with a car on it
and and been and bin bags full of
clothes turned on oh really yeah i was
such a [ __ ] i didn't even tell her that
we didn't even tell her damn bro
yes yeah but it's a very irish thing
just move
yeah like guess what i got you for
christmas an apartment yeah like there
you go yeah but that's insane
yeah that's like i know guys in ireland
to be like yeah i got a dumper and next
they'll come back be like we're engaged
yeah yeah they're like too weak
oh it's most i think it's most men or
it's it's hard to just communicate with
a woman it's like looking in the face of
like
a puppy
i'm gonna break something
right i i didn't have the balls to do it
but i was like breaking hearts left
right and center because
you know
i i am a man of means with a level of
fame right
so you know and not not but ugly
so i'm like a good package
to people right right and those so like
it'd be just like tough shelf a girl
would come in and go right i
she come walks into pants down palace
yeah and then goes i actually pause i'm
gonna put a pause on this because i want
to wife him oh yeah oh you remember he
told me that so uh there wasn't a lot of
sex happening because girls would just
go this is this is a good deal i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna play my cards here
yes did you when uh in britain what time
do y'all use you lose y'all's
virginities at like in the uk is it like
10 or 11 or is it 17 like uh a lot of
guys i say it's 15 to 17. now
and indoors are outdoors people doing it
more than a field oh wow
well i was a uh a latch latch door what
do you call them in america latch key
kid so you had the so
you were if you was home nobody else it
was just you well yeah so i i took my
the girl back to mine oh
and then i was like i was i was i can't
do that i thought i'm scared i can't do
this of course and then as she was
leaving i saw all of my friends faces
pointing and laughing at me like lino
and giuseppe and emma and pete and tate
all going ah
and i was like no i must do this oh
laughing i touched you laughing because
no laughing because i wasn't gonna do it
oh so i go upstairs and i go into my
room and it's a single bed
and we can't fit on it oh yeah
only room
nowhere really my mom's
that's all right you're a bad man
what about you marky how did you get rid
of it huh
i remember i was grounded so there was a
time crunch
and this girl was like oh my friend
wants to meet you oh this is bad i was
wearing white jeans it was that
christmas oh yeah and i met her like
behind the wall like we're in mock and
stuff it was raining
and she was just kept giving me green
lights oh yeah to keep going at one
point i was on my knees and mock oh
never knew what i was doing not a clue
i was just like instead of raining and
stuff and
just it happened but i didn't realize
that there was an ending that's
beautiful i just thought you were just
doing it and i was like okay
hold on so so there was no ending for
you no wow damn i just because i didn't
even know what it was
yeah but like mine was over in seconds
might have always i've ended i had sex
earlier i am not yeah people doing sex
they start breaking a sweat i'm like
how would you ever break a sweat dude i
can start a tv dinner and i am done with
sex but
i with enough time to [ __ ] be right
by everybody i don't have sex with
people i didn't fancy just to have long
sex oh wow oh damn now we're talking
issues yeah that was an irish thing too
you'd fantasize you'd have sex with your
bed but you wouldn't fantasize about the
hottest girl is the girl that you would
have sex would have no one found out oh
so how old were you
i was i think maybe
i want to say maybe 15 or something
behind a bowling alley in our town
and you could hear the pins going down
inside you know giving me power
i felt like it did anyway you know just
hearing that you know like people in
there just
yes you know
here's a question for you and people
started throwing rocks at us as well
just like in the gaza strip
or like in the middle east
and i was just doing what i could man
so they started throwing rocks at you
because they knew that you were having
sex yeah the friends that were throwing
their yeah they were excited or they
were trying to you know cause mayhem or
something you know or just be a part of
it i think they were jealous it's like i
can't be there with this rockwell and
they would throw a rock over okay so
he's a question
can you remember the third person that
you had sex with
i can't remember the second
no because like i remember the second
but i don't know a name
oh wow
second or okay second person you had sex
with
no idea that's weird isn't it yeah that
is weird isn't this yeah
yeah
and then third is just like what could
be anyone yeah i haven't reached the
third person here yeah they could walk
up right now and i'd have no idea yes
please very pleased to me
oh we've met before
oh yeah
have you ever spoke to your first
since
no
but i put an a i've put her name in a
song
of mine and perhaps i shouldn't have
done that
because she'll be a mom oh yeah you know
you're like you talk to yourself i think
it's some i think it depends on the
woman some women don't mind if you kind
of idolize moments like that or not
idolized but like uh
put them in the memoriums or whatever
yeah
like dead
was it deborah that was no no it wasn't
deb man deb was willing though i know
that
deb is always willing is deborah a name
in your country oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah i did have sex with one of the
first viewers there bro
unbelievable man so um
this guy's like a halfway house for your
time okay i feel like question have you
been close to
[Music]
having
uh a committed relationship with
somebody no
never i've been in some but i've just
always been like cheating or running
around i just think there's some i have
some
like complete
agitation towards like
anything
i don't want to say owning me but i
think things like that feel like they
own me like a relationship or anything
saying this is mine so now you're a
sober person yeah would you
do the same thing would you cheat
on somebody being the theo that you are
now at 41 years old
i think that's why for the past like i
haven't gotten in a relationship in a
long time you know and now it's been
about four years but
uh
because i got to do some work in some of
that space you know i'm trying to work
in slaa right now
and
you just even just like little things
like go two weeks without interacting
with
texting anything with women you know
just little things like that to try and
like just get on your own two feet you
know just so i'm not using interactions
with women as an outlet for like
uncomfort
that's what i do i get a little
uncomfortable and then it's like i'll
maybe set up a date sometimes so i want
to have things be more meaningful and
i'm going through my steps again right
now so i've had some slips over the uh
yeah yeah me too oh right yeah not over
the pandemic but in general have you
come close to being with somebody that
you just think is
she's amazing
there was a girl i was seeing that was
really great uh
and i think now when i think about it
makes me feel kind of sad because i
wasn't i didn't really meet her halfway
you know and because then i feel bad
because i kind of monopolized their time
you know that's what i feel the worst
about i think sometimes you monopolize
their time how
by like knowing i wasn't really ready to
have a strong commitment but
letting them believe that i was you know
and how long ago was that
it was probably the last relationship i
was in it's honestly been all of them
really but
i think it hurts more the older we get
because it's like you know people's time
is more precious to them
and also you know you think that you're
going to
have this all sorted
uh uh in the near future yeah and then
you walk through the horizon and you're
41. yeah and it's not sorted
and it's still the problem that it was
when you were 24. yeah it's a little
better when i look at mark it's almost
like
you know like in uh the movie where the
christmas people where they go look in
the window and they see the past yeah so
that's where i was kind of
yeah so
progress
so there's been some progress but it's
just it's got it's a little bit of
stagnation but you're right it's like
yeah i thought things would be different
where i'm at and i'm not so you
basically have to give the booze up when
it comes to sex you basically have to do
the same thing that you did with booze
and drugs but also with sex and the
flirting and the and i don't know how
you deal with social media because i met
my wife before instagram i met my wife
before facebook i met my wife before
tick tock and all of those things but
like if i'd have been around then that
would have been an extra thing that i
have to
un-addict myself from yeah
that's the thing for so much
temptation yeah it's unreal you think oh
i really like this girl and then
just the most unbelievable girl be like
hey what are you up to
yeah i'll be driving home trying to get
home and marcus send me some images
somewhere what about you know donna's
going to be there and i'm like
you know i just
i ca i i live vicariously through yeah
through mark how do you do it like this
one
like what
and he's like
this one yeah
it's it's it's mental it's mental he's
mental i live vicariously through him
and the cops even show up vicariously
it's like even interested in my visions
but it is tough you were saying
something there you're like oh you think
it's going to be different soon that's
funny because i always think that too
why yeah we're walking through the
horizon yeah yeah you will find yourself
in the place yeah yeah be like oh give
it a six months and then i'll be ready
for it yeah and then it's two years
later you're like we're still having fun
yeah yeah still having fun the fun one
and now especially in la the fun is all
the there's always the possibility like
you can you're gonna have to be the
bachelor yeah
and so even if you don't you turn them
down you walk down the street thinking
i'm a bachelor
somebody wants me to be a bachelor you
go home you leave your family
and you're the bachelor
but it's true it's always that
temptation out here there's this weird
thing and you can just you could be at
the cleaners here and see like a beaut
you know it's like it's it's it's never
ending what they called the you've got
to catch them all you've got to get them
or what they're called pokemon pokemon
go
get more yeah that's it and it's like
i'll think i like a girl sometimes and
i'll be like oh i should text her and i
swear to god i'll just be like [ __ ]
what's her name
and i'll just be like let's begin with c
d
and then
in my head i'm like come on i really
like this
oh dude and then someone else text me
and i'm like okay it's it's you
[Laughter]
yeah that is that is a prison to find
yourself in yeah is it a prisoner or
open field
well it's an open prison
it's an open prison that you can you can
leave at any time but it's um you know
if you know that you are going to fall
in love or fall and lost with absolutely
everything
at any given time
it kind of it kind of makes sense that
you go oh well that's me and this is
what's happening i just don't
i don't do anything about it
yeah that's kind of where i find myself
a little time it's like
or that's where i'm wondering if that's
where i'm at like yeah because i just
don't you think things will be different
like you're saying in a few years i'll
get there some will be and then you get
there and you're like oh and i don't i'm
not a big run around or anything even i
just noticed that i give in to like
little things of of affection attention
just little things like that that i
don't want
to con i just don't want the same thing
i want to see if there's a different
possibility
you know because even if just like you
know flirting with the girl or
uh i'll feel uncomfortable i feel like
out of bed i'll set up a date you know
let me go on a date that'll help you
know like um
so i just wanna but i'm not i find
myself in spaces where i'm not making
myself really available you know
if that makes sense because i'm just
my
the reasons i'm doing stuff aren't
motivated always from a place of like uh
maybe this is what's or from love or
anything like that they're just kind of
motivated from a place of like um
what feels kind of comfortable what
would be fun you know and sometimes it's
just funny i met my missus when i'd
retired
because things got really sort of was it
dicey out there for you mentally just
completely ill and just like well it's
my career that's doing this so i might
as well not do my career yeah we'll
retire from work from the famous or from
the singing no no no from the singing
yeah yeah from the singing so like i was
really i was retired and then i met my
missus and we just had
three years with her of not going out
wow oh really yeah so we were just at
the house and it just cemented this
thing and then
i realized that i need purpose and i'm
ambitious and i need to go out and do
things so i unretired and went out into
the world but now i'd cemented this
relationship with this person and i went
back out into the world and i was like
oh i i can't do the things that i used
to do i so how do you
you you clue in quite quickly really
okay so i i'm not flirting right i'm not
going to the club yeah i'm not going to
the pub
um
and i have to on
i have to own everything that i used to
on oh yeah and i
i did it
[ __ ] did it and if i can do it
anybody well not you
but if i can do it anybody can do it
no i like hearing i appreciate you kind
of sharing some of that man because yeah
i think that's just kind of where i'm
finding myself you know and i'm not and
part of me i'm kind of excited about i
had like five days where i didn't have
any interaction with anyone and i was
doing real good
and i started to feel like a good
relationship with my higher power i was
like really like oh man i had a little
bit more time i was looking at my place
like oh maybe i'd like uh do a art or
something you know like or get a candle
or something you know
because like everything in my house is
the previous owners it's like it's all
like their stuff you know like there's
pictures of their family in the bathroom
it's just i guess but don't don't you
also think that uh when i get a missus
she'll do all of that yeah yeah yeah but
i don't want to just hurry and misses in
just to get you know a lot of 41 you're
hurrying
[Laughter]
think yeah oh yeah that's true yeah
women complain about that about guys in
l.a they'll be like i'm not ready to
settle down and there's 57.
that's very easy i don't want to be that
guy yeah i want to get some i want to at
least get in a place now where i could
at least try i think to have a
relationship so i'm getting big vibes
that you'd be an ace dad oh thanks man
yeah i don't care yeah no not you
no i'm getting like big vibes that you'd
be an awesome daddy oh thanks yeah i
want to tell you about a company that
i've been using for our web presence
their beautiful company beautiful outfit
and they've started the last website
you'll ever need no more
no more
paying 10 grand to get a cider some
crazy this is it they do it it's the
last website you'll ever need they did
hours
theovonne.com you can check it out
it's just 498 dollars to start and then
after that it's just 249 dollars a month
and that's it
they build everything
you get on with them you consult
they do it they revamp
revamping i don't even know what it is
man it's like sound like a damn uh
you know uh something like somebody
gonna suck your blood but it's different
you know it sound like a dracula's son
who's maybe been doing pills or whatever
and got sent up to alaska for rehab
but this is different i'm talking about
modify.com
slash t-h-e-o
go there check it out they'll do all the
they build the site they'll do the
branding they'll figure it all out for
you it's the last website you'll ever
need it's simple if you're running a
business they can help they changed my
website they put it together they did an
update the other day gave us a new
design bing we're living
we're living well on the on the web
modify
m-o-d-i-p-h-y dot com slash t-h-e-o
i want to let you know you know i was
trying to get a loan
mortgage loan home
you know i wanted to get a day home i
wanted to live in something
i didn't want to be outdoors anymore
i didn't want to be battling the rain i
wanted them more
mortgage
and the problem was i had some dings on
my credit i mean like somebody had
showed up with a bat and just beat it
just beat my damn credit like it had
been mugged
but i needed help
and so
i contacted
this company that i'm about to tell you
about man
i'm serious i contacted this company and
within a couple months i had the dings
off my report and i was able to get a
better mortgage
bridge credit solutions that's who
they're different they're backed by a
100 percent money back guarantee for any
items that cannot be removed off your
credit
i needed items removed i got them
removed and then bing bong
i got the loan because my
credit score was better
i i can't even tell you how much it
changed things for me you will not find
the 100 money back guarantee anywhere
else in the industry you know what
you're paying for at the beginning of
the repair it's written into the
contract no job is too big or too small
bridge credit solutions caters to all
types of clients that's right
they will guarantee removal of certain
negative items in as quick as 24 hours
schedule your free audit in three easy
steps
zoom or phone call
and get a free three bureau credit
report twenty five dollar value with
thirty days of free credit monitoring
and identity theft protection when you
sign up through this link bridge credit
solutions dot com
i'm not joking i'm living in a home
because
i was able to get it because they helped
with the credit man my credit was banged
up
my credit was an icu dog
um
so bridge
credit solutions.com
t-h-e-o once scheduled a bridge credit
strategist will contact you to review
your report with you
they work
check them out if you have the same
issue i have you want to get that loan
but you got some dings you need the
better score to get the better loan
amount then you save the money on the
loan bing bong
yeah i could think i could be a good dad
dude
you know i think uh some of it would be
a little dicey bro you know but you must
have thought that if there's kids
no no not that it would be dicey as [ __ ]
what for him to be a doctor for you yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah absolutely i like i'm
an i'm an
agrophobic that can't look after himself
i'm depressed
and i'm full of anxiety
what have i got to offer
yeah that's that's you know it's like i
wasn't going to get married and i wasn't
going to have kids just because of
the nothingness that i had to offer the
world
where those points exist
and now i've got four kids and it's true
i have nothing to
offer your kids you could put them in
another wing of the house man you could
put a kid in a room until he's six
you know i i still i still feel that way
about the kids you know it's like i i'm
i i'm like
sporadic dad yeah i mean i mean i'm in
i'm
putting the football
and doing art and writing songs
i mean like you know i am i am sporadic
also you know that was another thing
about kids is that if i'm agrophobic if
i have children it will mean that i have
to leave the house
or the kids will smoke me out of that
did it work
not really no
they put it like i feel that everyone
doesn't think they can be a dad and then
it just happens do you think but that's
bad that when it happens that way i
think it's not really the best way you
know yeah like um
yeah mark is unbelievable i can't even
believe i'm sitting here with him but um
[Laughter]
sorry sorry yeah
this guy's just one of a kind man
there's just really nobody looking like
you've told me before you're like you
were saying something you're describing
a bad guy and then you're like you're
that guy
and i was like wait no no no take that
back and you're like no no i was
describing him to say you're that guy
i was like no but i do think it is like
oh i might be that guy now but in three
years
do you think you could ever get to a
place where you could oh yeah i think us
really yeah but i think no rob has made
me realize oh think away
yeah yeah
then you die
yeah
yeah because like you're you're not
there yeah
you're like wrongs away from that
yeah this ain't even a great spot
you better get over here pretty quick
but then mark's the guy you go to if you
want to know what's going on what's fun
you know he like is always kind of keen
on like what's what's good out there you
know i'm a fun guy yeah yeah do they
have like a lot of uh i feel like in
england and in the uk that's all of you
guys right
that they have more superstition than
they do over in america oh yeah i think
so is that true you think well i i think
anxiety in ireland just comes from your
mom mm-hmm she'll be like don't don't
touch chicken ever you get salmonella
you'll die yeah and every time now i'm
near a chicken i'm like i hear my mom's
voice
or like
prayers catalysm catalogs or whatever
yeah what we are yeah catholics
we're like laps capitalists yeah we're
catalogues yeah it's insane though
because you'll be like don't do that
don't
christian don't do that don't do that
you're like what the [ __ ] should i do
that's where my sweating comes in oh
you're sweating always and it's weird
too like in ireland if i told my friends
i went on a date with a girl they'd be
like that's gay oh yeah and people die
in ireland all the time from coughing
and everything huh you always see that
in the movies
people dying from like you're watching
movies from the 1800s
well
whatever manicus
yeah exactly that's exactly that's a
slow cable mate yeah you got some
pleurisy yeah yeah really what's that
movie with tom cruise firing away he
thinks it's back in the ireland
you just see a lot of people coughing
and not doing well
still dealing with the spanish flu yeah
yeah
he thinks people are there like a
confident napkin yeah he's got blood on
it
have you left america much
yeah yeah we did us we did some shows in
our in the uk last year two years ago
how did they go they did well
we did um
[Music]
manchester london
glasgow he thinks of glasgow
shout out glasgow yeah
so it was fun man i really liked it it
was i think during i don't know if it
was winter or if it was like at the
beginning of the pan i don't know what
was going on
but it was kind of a quiet time but
durbin what was that what was this
durban
durban's like south africa that's
australia i don't know where he went not
durban
this is about yeah this is a different
time
so what did what was this
the um the uh
superstitions yeah
oh well like i in ireland here's the
dumb one touch water right touch wood
and then i saw a guy after a soccer game
one time and he was like this
yeah that's ocd though yeah no but he
goes why's that you're like i'm blessed
i'm saying
hail mary fulgres our father and i i was
like that sawdum and the next time with
a big exam i swear i was like this
mary
but that's that's ocd but y'all got more
ghosts yeah i got more older stuff over
there i'm saying because of time and
everything you guys have a lot more
ghosts over there no oh yeah you are
closer to the woowoo in los angeles than
you are in england
it is so more paranormal and weird and
ufo yeah we actually got a question i
forgot about this i came in right here
hi theo my name's gabby i'm from new
zealand big fan of yours um actually
managed to catch a show of yours like in
2017 at the comedy store really really
randomly when i was in la for a week
just on holidays so i was really really
stoked uh to catch that um also a big
fan of robbie williams as well out of
michael i do have a question for him
um i saw him on the skinwalker ranch
documentary
um i was quite surprised to see him
there and i just wondered what sort of
interest he had in
you know paranormal experiences or if
he's had any alien experiences you know
anything in that kind of realm i would
just be really interested to find dark
arts maybe it's called space
spirit yeah you've been involved with it
i've had loads of experience and more
that's obviously from the uk
no i just that's what i find hard to
believe robbie is that no listen i've
got a thousand-year-old home
in
england right it used to be a manor yeah
it used to be one of henry viii's wives
houses
catherine park
and
i feel closer to the weird
here in los angeles than i do back home
something like a transmit lost angels
los angeles so it's a transmitter that
turns on when i'm here that i'm
things haven't happened since the kids
have been around but do you want me to
tell you my ufo stories yeah if you guys
okay
so if you came to do you know it
uh probably so i am you need to get
abducted
[Laughter]
so i am sat on a sun lounger with a girl
beside me so it's over 17 years ago
because of the wife they can say over 17
years old she was over 17 years old
we've had some issues in our industry
and um
i'm looking we're both looking up at the
sky
and all of a sudden
i would say the size of
a quarter of a football field
your football field
square
matte black
just
silently came in completely sober
silently came in
and there was yellow underneath it and
um it sort of had like this rtex
artexing feel um
with matte black underneath it it came
in silently
and then silently left
and i could have hit it with the tennis
ball no way really yeah
jesus
you saw it
absolutely positively did you feel like
then that you got to see something like
that because you were famous did that
ever cross your mind like is there a
reason why i get to see this is it like
is the other side trying to communicate
with me well and yeah there is because
of narcissism yes there is
there is there is that
yeah but there's so many thoughts that's
one of them
um but i also thought
oh that's ours i didn't think it was
aliens from a different planet oh that's
huge i i i
inside me just went
there's some exotic technology that
we're not supposed to have that we do
have but it's ours i didn't feel as
though it was little green men from
outer space
and that was in the uk
no it was here oh
the other one is i wrote this song about
alien abduction called arizona it's not
one of my best songs it's a b-side
but i'm sort of like listening to it in
the studio and smoking a cigarette
overlooking the san fernando valley
and um you whittle you whittle at lyrics
to get them right as best as possible
and uh
arizona comes on and this gold ball
appears in the sky over the san fernando
valley and i'm like
nice try venus
i know that's venus you're not going to
fool me i'm not going to be like one of
those
ufo people
and then i thought it was venus during
the day oh yeah arizona the song
ends
the gold ball blinks out and i'm like
interesting
put the song on again so they put the
song on again and the gold ball comes
back
songs about alien abduction and i'm like
now you've got my attention
song ends and the gold ball
beeps out again
i'm like wow that's
a happy coincidence
so i said to the lads i said let's come
out and look at this put the song on and
look over there
song goes on ball comes up song ends
ball goes out wife arrives babe these
things happen come see this look over
there song boom gold ball
song ends gold ball comes out six times
it happens
after the sixth time me the wife and my
two friends go back into the bedroom
where the uh the studios and we go [ __ ]
what the and as we say that
a black strip
comes through the door about
20 feet away
black strip like this
elongates through the middle of us
elongates through the middle of us goes
to the window and then follows itself
out like that oh what yeah jesus what
the
yeah listen i've got loads and loads and
loads no that's too many already man
yeah i've got a [ __ ] yeah i've got
loads of them
wow yeah so
there's did you feel like it okay so
that instance did you feel like that was
like a
human like a person you feel like that
was related to any territory or
i
if i was guessing what i think that
might be or might not be is
interdimensional yeah
or
maybe we're trying to or you know or a
figment of all our imaginations
everything's on the table nothing's off
the table could be duct tape between
different realms or something i'm saying
you don't know some of the things that
are holding together it was exactly like
you know duct tape yeah it came through
the room and then went and followed
itself out of the window damn yeah
i could see something like that in a few
200 years from now you order duct tape
into the room
and it shows up you know do you know
what skin walker ranch is uh-uh okay
google skin walker ranch and check
that's what the nice lady was talking
about i'm on a documentary about this
ranch
in utah i think it is
where
things happen
really
damn that's a dark artist
who's some of my favorite british people
james blake
yeah yeah
is that just
just a just
that's just a random
james blake's a nice english person
yeah i love him who else do i think is
great
oh i know who darren till who's that
darren till fighter
yeah
big fan of his
[Laughter]
i don't know that many others actually
the beatles you yeah the beatles but
i'm not that big on them you too uh you
two is okay yeah youtube's okay the
rolling stones yeah rolling stones
rolling stones
who else black coffee in bed have you
heard that song
this feels like an alien experience
what else i'm trying to think of things
that are british because we didn't have
a lot of when we were growing up they
didn't even have a lot of like i
remember the map in our town canada they
even didn't say canada on it said like
it had a picture of a wolf attacking a
boy in a coat
and that was the whole thing for canada
you know
if we if we had a map here could you
could you point to england do you think
no i know i couldn't point i could point
to the area that it's in though
could you point to hawaii
yep
could you point to montana
no
say i can point to montana could you
point to florida yes
where are you from florida's easy
because i'm from louisiana okay so
florida was like our main
florida was like the main place you even
went like if you saw somebody i remember
when i was a kid if you know somebody
their shirts have florida on it you were
like damn dude those people are trapped
what about what about rhode island could
you
no i could find that nobody could find
that i could it's the clitoris of
america
nobody isn't isn't it defined in that
smallest state yeah
you're welcome
well it'll get taken over soon
i'm sure it'll get taken over soon
um
what else do we have let's get another
good question that came in here for the
gents eh
first of all hope these are doing well
secondly i am right now stuck in
quarantine for two weeks because
australia does that to you i'm at our
willy land yes theo you've got to come
to a flip off this ramp back here so do
you robbie actually my mom would be
stoked but my question is
when do you think the world is going to
be back to normal and
do you think it is and if yes how long
do you think it's going to take 11 years
old gang gang
he's a dude i mean i've never met him
but you can just tell that he's the
nicest person there's a great thing
he came on here he was on here once so
was chris hanson who you mentioned
earlier was on here oh really i guess
we've had an interesting group
mark
we've been we've done it all
probably the best so the question is
when do we think this is going to be
over are you shocked at how much like
because we've already given two years of
our life to this thing has been two it's
fine it's been a long time man imagine
people this is [ __ ] that breaks my heart
when you think of people that was like
you know trying to maybe women that was
hoping to have a child and looking to
meet someone and they don't have that
chance now because of
i'm not saying it's not a deadly disease
but it's not this deadly man
that's my thoughts on i mean i probably
shouldn't have brought that into it but
when do you guys think it'll be over
that's more that's a better
i think i think um
every summer we're going to think it's
over and then every winter it's going to
come back
and i i every time that i've had a guess
when this is going to be over i've been
completely wrong so when this started it
was like end of january february nearly
two years ago and i was like this is
going to be over by june
and now we are two christmases nearly
into it and it's still
going strong
it's
it's terrifying you know it's it's
terrifying for many many reasons but
like selfishly and personally i haven't
been able to gig i haven't been able to
do a tour oh yeah you know and um
i i you know i i'm hopefully going to go
on tour
end of next year but then you see how
the end of this year's gone am i going
to be able to do that uh am i going to
be able to look after my four kids
uh keep them in the lifestyle that
they're accustomed to
who knows
my spidey senses
which were so wrong last time
mine say we've got this for five years
really but i thought another year or
maybe but as you said i forgot about it
yeah i forgot about like summer seems
okay
and then winter is like oh it's a new
strain
but in some parts of the country it's
not you can go to different parts of
america and they're not even
doing knowledge enough yeah really
and they're not the hospitals aren't so
it's it's definitely interesting how
different parts it's more of a it's more
catered to you know it's more or it's
more uh there's more preventative
measures
i think well there is you know there is
a topic that it would do as all
a great favor if we didn't discuss what
we really thought
[Laughter]
you know sort of
because you've walked through the
horizon you're past 30 now you've done a
bit of time on the planet yeah where are
you with the uh is is it just like a an
oblique concept that's out here
somewhere the commitment that's settling
down or is it in the fourth or fourth or
in your mind it's in when i'm hungover
so it's something to feel depressed and
anxious about yeah be like oh that would
be nice it's kind of like the song when
you need love yeah
when you need tension and then when the
serotonin comes back i'm like oh i'm
having a great time okay yeah here's the
thing do you need to be in a
relationship do you need to have
commitment do you need i don't think so
at the moment
but like your moment you think you're
still you're still looking out of these
eyes that still think they're 19 20 21
yeah yeah but they're not yeah
i don't think so at the moment yeah it's
like you're gonna be having a free bus
pass
pretty soon yeah do you know what i mean
and you know so i just don't think so at
the moment like i'm in a very happy
committed relationship and my life is so
much better because of it i don't want
to go anywhere i'll be with anybody
other than my wife that aside
do you need to be in a relationship yeah
maybe you don't need to you i don't
think you need to man you're doing well
you need ladies like do you need to
i don't know man
i always have a problem i just always
think something's wrong
you know i have a lot of whatever that
is like oh
i'm always like there's always some
emotional deficit going on you know the
dis ease yeah oh yeah but it's a disco
yeah i have a constant discomfort um
yeah i have a constant i have a constant
discomfort do you not have a constant
discomfort because you booze and you
sort of self-medicate yeah yeah because
like i i'll have i'm going to come here
okay
yeah like i've got anxiety now let me
ask you this right
you don't have a drink for four weeks
what's your mental state like in four
weeks time oh i'm not i'm just a bit
bored but i also have pain in my lower
back okay i quit because you're drinking
for pain huh no no no oh you're an
american then distress you're in a
youtube what's up i remember like i
stopped like for four weeks a couple
years ago
sober october or something and i was
like i got i couldn't lie down that's
your liver bub no the pain in my back
just was like not does your back feel
round and it's kind of down over here by
the bottom it was there is it here yeah
is it there yeah that's your liver
that's your liver man no no no this is
after four weeks do you think you give a
soft round bacon yeah because it's it's
in because it's in constantly inflamed
but then you don't you don't drink so
you come with nothing to nominate you're
going to test this is the subject we're
better off that time
so it's not there no it is yeah it's in
the bone oh no no it was like in here
you're going to pass this down that's
liver all right so but when i was
walking you're gonna make this a crack
rock dude you're gonna pass us down
right away yeah walk into my booze yeah
disappeared speaking of the rolling
stones you're gonna roll a couple out of
your wiener one day
from all of that drink specials building
up in him
to be the best thing mark would be like
at the bar you know with that and some
of the high tables he'd put his computer
on the table at like a nightclub get his
computer out there just hit a nightclub
get his ear ear things and pretend he
was a dj dude
so all the drunk chicks would come up
and talk to me he'd be like yeah i'll
play it in a second just [ __ ]
emailing people those little tips are
you are you writing
yeah you'd be creative or what what yeah
what's your outlet apart from
do you have any time outside of
podcasting and comedy
outside of podcasting and comedy what
are your
creative outlets or your outlets at all
it probably has been kind of uh
i think socializing has been one so
that's something i do want to cut back
on which includes like dating
erroneously
um how do you do with socializing
i do okay i think fortunately with up it
builds a lot of that is built into it so
it's like you almost
i can't kind of sometimes stand up as my
socializing because you're at the club
do you feel okay so you feel like your
tribe is comedians
so you you feel comfortable within that
tribe of people i think so most of the
time outside of that type of people how
are you socially i like spending time
within the
recovery room the recovery group talking
with people like that yeah i love that
kind of stuff um but i need more time
for myself i got to do some things for
myself i do everything it's just been
work
so i think part of it so you're going to
you are checking yourself into a men's
recovery place
to give yourself some space
so you're not are you
is that like rehab or is that like
a meditation place
i don't know actually i'm talking to
like five or six of them right now just
trying to decide you know investigating
and how long will you spend there i
think i'll probably just do two weeks
okay and what do you hope to get from it
um i would just want to think i want to
build a relationship with my higher
power i want to have i want to go over
like some intimacy issue kind of stuff
and what else dude did you have a
relationship with a higher power when
you were growing up no no
and what what what is your higher power
just god just god yeah
a god of your understanding or a
religious god a christian god yeah i
kind of attach it to a christian guy
because that's what's most familiar for
me but i'm a i just i think a guy i just
believe in god
have you had your atheist moment
uh
i think i did when i was younger i
didn't think that god existed all this
kind of anger but i don't think i have
that anymore i want there to be a god i
want there to be something that's
that cares about me you know do you pray
do you pray in the morning and at night
yeah
and you've started to do that since you
were in recovery
yeah mark
no no
you need a cup i'll throw i'll fire off
of you for you man yeah definitely but i
i was i was telling rob earlier i almost
there was a girl recently that i was
chatting to well a way back and she was
very much into the bible and religion
and i can't myself like well like i
thought i was like oh yeah i'd love to
read the bible too oh yeah
not lying in the moment but afterwards i
was like what am i doing i can't read
she's like you want to go to mass i'm
like it's one of my favorite things to
do oh i vomited on a woman once on
accident and uh
and then met her at church in the
morning she's like you're not gonna meet
me and i was like i'll meet you and i'll
show up just
eyes just so red just
so what was your drug of choice
i think just
feelings my own feelings is my biggest
drug just thinking of just
just my brain is just my thoughts and my
feelings i never really struggled that
much with addiction with like substances
you know i think i relate a lot more
with like uh
slaa type stuff and those type of
things how do you sleep
i don't sleep that great yeah i mean
either me neither
what do you think that is you think
we're also just getting to be an age
where we don't sleep well you think it's
kind of like a well i i a new thing for
me like 47 is like
peeing five times in the water
the worst thing you can't drink any
water after about maybe 7 p.m really
because it just keeps coming out of you
really that's why i see old people
they're just traveling around pee in
different places yeah they're like dogs
yeah like it's just started to happen oh
where i you know like normally i would
close my eyes and when i did fall off to
sleep i would stay asleep yeah really
but now
i go to sleep and then i wake up five
times does that i really don't know
jesus that's happened in the last 12
months well there's machines talking in
the distance too while we're laying
there it's getting [ __ ] pretty weird
you know that information is traveling
through the air into your phones and
computers and printers and
satellites and all did you have you been
addicted to ambient at any point no
never i would do it what what's that
again it's uh nighttime baby oh really
yeah
were you uh oh yeah were you really was
it good
what'd you do what would you do on it
huh uh sleep eat
oh yeah so i would get up and have a pie
eh so i would sleepy yeah there was one
time we were in uh ireland and i was
doing a show and they bought
they bought 32 euro so like 32 dollars
worth of chocolate
that's a lot right yeah and because of
ambien i ate 32. no wait worth of
chocolate aiming asleep
what
completely asleep
it's like a japanese game show yeah
yeah you could do that yeah that's
unbelievable and did that cause you to
shut it down you're like i'm gonna roll
the dice again
see what else i can eat no by that time
i'm in on i'm addicted so i i needed to
go to sleep i'm also on tour and if i
don't sleep and i'm on tour then
i'm gonna i'm gonna just not perform the
way that i performed in the last gigs
and oh my god and i'm tired anyway so if
i so all the way through that tour i was
sort of like
living like a monk
food wise
during the day sort of my body as a
temple but then at night i'd be taking
these ambien and then i would be eating
the mini bar no way yeah yeah
in the menu do you actually you don't
remember any of it ah you don't remember
don't remember any of it
but also another one was sort of like my
security on tour they
they
they'd have the ambien and i'd be like
can i have them so they give me the
ambient right
and then i'd go next door
and then i'd have my ambien and i fall
asleep on the ambien and then
then i would get up yeah completely
naked yeah go through the security room
and have a conversation with them
as lucidly as this
but completely naked and asleep and
asleep that's beautiful and then i'd
wake up the next it's like joe biden
i'll wake up the next morning and i'd go
i'd say i didn't do it did i
and then this luke on their eyes would
just be like
yeah yeah yeah you did you did do it
that must be tough to get off
yeah it was yeah yeah
jeez because like like you said if you
need sleep that much and then you can't
sleep you're like just give me the
[ __ ] pill that's the worst especially
if you're on tour like if you get
stressed out like i got it if i'm gonna
get my sleep i'm not
dude dude i've been in positions where i
play wembley stadium wow
i'm awake
at 12 o'clock the next morning
and i've got to play wembley stadium
again in eight hours time and i haven't
been asleep and there's no there's no
drugs i'm completely and utterly sober
it's just my mind is go because
you're in front of 80 000 people oh yeah
and you've just shared this mass
experience with them where you just like
you create your own drug inside of you
so you're you're creating dopamine
adrenaline serotonin but like this crazy
amount because there's 80 000 people
looking at you and then
you go back to the room and you're sort
of like ah
yeah but then you've got to go do it
again
and that's why that's why touring
crushes me it's like do you enjoy
touring no i don't at all do you enjoy
the gigs that feel spiritual and
otherworldly oh my god i couldn't even
tell you what they're like they're on
[ __ ] believable you know that moment
where you're in the pocket
you're in the pocket
you can't miss and everything that you
do and you just free-flow it yes yes
that is absolutely otherworldly and
incredible how often does that happen on
tour not very often why because i've had
three hours sleep in the last week oh
god
and i've you you've then got to do the
thing you you know your performance
you've then got to go and do the thing
again which is why that you know i got
the addicted to ambien
thing that i did um
last few weeks have you tried magnesium
to sleep yeah i've been taking magnesium
and ice it helps if i remember to take
it yes so how many milligrams are you
taking two pills two white pills of it
100 200 milligrams
i don't know
so i feel i feel it i think i feel it
yes so did you take it last night
yeah yeah so
i think the magnesium has been giving me
anxiety though [ __ ] oh really [ __ ] so
i've been taking magnesium a lot over
the last couple of weeks and i've
noticed that i'm grumpy with the misses
are you sleeping
huh are you sleeping
yeah i'm sleeping well there you go i
mean you can't have it all
yeah but so
i i've noticed the anxiety too so i've
knocked the magnesium on the head last
couple of days and the anxiety is gone i
don't know oh really so
it's a dirty bad it's a [ __ ] dirty
experiment always going on inside of us
it feels like
it's a real time to go to sleep what
time to wake up
i would sleep probably about 11 30 woke
up at three in a fit of anger for about
40 minutes and then went back to sleep
bit of anger in the middle of the night
yeah i'll do it i'll figure it out yeah
yeah
i've never heard it
so you wake up in a fit of anger about
not being able to sleep i wake up no my
brain starts thinking about something
then i'll start doing something online
and then i'm angry
because i don't have a lot of time
during the day sometimes so it's like oh
[ __ ] i got a little bit of time
and then i'm doing but then i need to go
back to sleep so i'll probably get into
a nap today so what is your nap is good
when you drool you ever had that yeah
when your face just kind of orgasms okay
but like daytime sleep
daytime sleep when you wake up from it
do you need sugar
oh yeah i do i haven't noticed that yeah
daytime sleep if i wake up i need
chocolate or i need you like the
groggiest yeah it's unreal but you're
freaking eating chocolate in your damn
sleep bro
crane right there i've knocked it on the
head not chocolate on the head cake on
the head really cake yeah you can't do
away with cake man i'll get married just
to have some damn cake boy i love cake
which is your favorite cake
my kind of like uh
let me think i like a um coconut cake
what about red velvet because i didn't
know red velvet existed until i came to
america and i was just like ah oh
yeah
and have you had this cake celebration
cake
and it's like got rainbow colors in it
and like skittles in the middle or
whatever it is what really oh it's a
real thing oh yeah
yeah i don't have uh it pisses people
off that i have no inclination to eat
you don't eat that's another thing that
nobody judges on is you not eating
an anorexic alcoholic yeah brother
you're sick you're sick yeah lay down
here we'll take your temperatures help
yeah like healthy but like i won't eat
if you put fries here i'd be like i'm
ground
like women would get upset if i went to
dinner once in a blue moon they're like
just try this i'd be like i'm okay i'm
okay now i just say i have gluten
and they're like oh i'm sorry dude in 20
years we're just gonna be having
smoothies nobody's gonna eat anymore
i had the kids gave me a bug and i lost
seven pounds in a week but it's awesome
yeah it was amazing but i've used it as
the great reset oh dietary wise oh you
actually
i thought you were going to eat more
cake no no no no because i wasn't caking
it and i wasn't chocolate in it how did
you kick them because
uh well but what i was doing which was
lying to myself is keto bars yeah have
you seen these keto bars keto bars and
protein balls
so you've seen these like bounce balls
and dada done all of these sort of
things basically they should just be
like calorie balls and calorie bars oh
so i was like i was not having the
chocolate or the cake but i was nailing
these things
so now what i've done with this great
reset is i've got rid of those and every
time i want one of those i go for a
banana or i go for an apple and it's
nowhere near as fun
but it works but you can't be old and
fat yeah you can be old but you can't be
fat yeah so i'm just trying my best not
be fat have you ever been fat
i was maybe fat when i was a little bit
when i was young like in the spring
but not as an adult have you been i
would do it yeah when i was young i
remember my nana called me fat i was on
tv singing like in a choir
oh and i had a close-up i think and i
came home i thought i was like in a boy
band
and then my nana was like i saw you on
tv you look very fat in the face
wow yeah and that messed me up yeah you
want to hear a weirder story after she
passed away i couldn't take photos
because i'd always be like this
yeah yeah yeah and after after she
passed away the first photo i took i was
just like
oh nana's dead
but it's so mean because like i loved
her
but i was like well i can smile again
she died during a pandemic eh
yeah i actually thought she died like a
year before i remember you told me that
yeah she was in like hospice
and then i was like asking my parents
every day is that how's nana she alive
and they're like yeah she's she's
hanging on and i asked like four or five
days in a row and i was like this is
getting morbid like i don't want to keep
bringing it off i want to be like so
anyway it's sunny here
was your nan
your example of love when you were
growing up was she just like a wonderful
person oh yeah
yeah she was but she'd feed me cake and
yeah oh yeah but she would call me fat
treat you warmly though yeah but she
said fat in a loving way oh you're fat
it didn't feel like it definitely no no
it would never would yeah
oh yeah like i didn't know i didn't my
brother saw me fix them hang on so your
grandma passed away just recently
certainly it's only just recently that
you've allowed yourself to smile with a
fuller face oh yeah yeah in fallout yeah
yeah just like just like out and about
now in los angeles you're like she's
dead
like if someone takes a photo i won't go
yeah you know when you make that dumb if
they're like hey make the nana's alive
face yeah i like
no i do i do that a lot i go like
really and there's another thing that
okay so side view so this here
okay so if you put your tongue on there
on your
oh
that's clever oh it makes your chin pop
out something we just take a photo
of us just like
yeah but you haven't you why have you
got the why have you why'd you do that
because you've got a chin oh yeah i just
like having a little bit of hair on
there it reminds me of like insecurity
what are you gonna do and you keep in
the mud i think you you're warm you rock
the mullet so
you've had it forever right i've had it
when i was a child i had it and then i
didn't have it when i moved out here for
a while and then i i just like my hair
long it doesn't feel for me it's not
like a gimmicky type of thing some
people get like
a gimmicky type of haircut that you know
for some purpose
i just feel most comfortable in it is it
oh and oh man
did you ever go through it did you go no
i'm losing my hair oh he's doing fine no
i'm doing all right but then if it
shines on the top of it it becomes like
baby's bomb so i went to go and have a
thatch i went to go and have the i've
heard that oh did you do it yeah i went
have it done and the guy was like bad
news because they harvest it from here
right yeah so bad news um your hair is
so thin
uh we can't harvest it from there we'll
do nothing so i was like i'm gonna have
a second opinion second opinion was your
hair is that thin we can't harvest it
from there it will do it will do damage
thank god you came see us because other
people would have harvested it and
[ __ ] it up oh so what i did was i had
these injections and i won't tell you
how much they were but they were
absolutely like a fortune two and two
vials of this stuff where they numb your
head
and then they do this they put these
vials in and in five months time your
hair will grow back much thicker and it
it costs the same price as my grandma's
house right
yeah
nothing nothing's happened
we're now seven months in and nothing's
happened you can't you you can't you
can't tell because but like when i'm on
stage and there's a 40 foot
screen of me at the back and i'm giving
it the bigger and then i'm doing the
sexy like that and they're going yeah
and then i looked behind me and this guy
was like double chair
and no hair
oh
thank you for humoring me
do you think it's hard to
that's one thing that's interesting
about like the way we capture ourselves
now and especially like at your level of
fame and popularity that you've had
robbie that
is it hard to live up to try and always
live up to that like live up to like
you know because you're captured at such
a young vibrant time in your life that
you gotta like [ __ ] you know well i was
i was um my nickname in the press was
blobby robbie through the 90s which
really damaged me
kind of thicker yeah not like i i have a
tendency to put a scone huh yeah yeah
and then and then go down again but like
damp scone but it sort of
it damaged me and it's something you
know it's like i don't want to look in
the mirror i don't want to look at
myself if i'm doing a photo shoot and
they'll say do you want to come and
check this out see how you look i'm like
no thanks
if i'm shooting a video they're like
that was a great take do you want to
come and look no thanks
so i just don't like looking at myself
which is another one of those things
when you're people are going can i have
my picture taken with you it's basically
going hey um you know all those things
that you hate about yourself
now is the time to hate yourself about
that yeah yeah i was
like your rock dj video where you're
stripping naked it's like ripped and
stuff
if i had like a really good video like
that and then saw a bad picture
i'd just self-hatred would be
well i'm body dysmorphic too yeah so
like being being like obese
and being body dysmorphic like the first
time that i was told i was body
dysmorphic a therapist and what does it
mean body dysmorphic you can't read that
or you cannot read
not sorry not read you can't like no you
think you're fat where you are
oh yeah so it was like a compliment
though when the therapist told me it's
like your body dysmorphic i was like
thank you
[Laughter]
like when your body dysmorphic and
obesity oh oh
that's awful because not only are you
fat but when you look at yourself you're
fatter than oh you're doubling down yes
jesus yes god
but then you know
you know you know that you know that one
where you're just like oh my look awful
and then 18 months later you look at
that phone you go i was in good shape oh
that's so nice
that's body dysmorphia oh dude because i
look good when i look at younger
pictures of myself i'm like god you were
a handsome guy if i if i only thought
then that i was handsome it would have
been such a different f instead of every
day thinking i was horrible you're a
striking looking guy you're a good
looking guy yeah like it saw you in the
um so you i'm happily married
pretty happily straight yeah
i saw you in the car park and decide
yeah i think i was a good looking lad
yeah
i think like you you waste your 20s
thinking you're ugly oh yeah you spend
the whole time like being like [ __ ] i
remember i remember i'd see a photo and
i'd be like i remember being so
uncomfortable that night thinking i look
like [ __ ] yeah i look bad yeah i know i
see that i'm like oh [ __ ] i was
dapper well let's put it how do we do it
okay here's the thing right
i'm in an owl everything large
everything
i know
i'm an m
i know i'm an m i haven't been in an m
for a long long time like i haven't been
an m for
15 years 17 years since i met the wife
and became happy really yeah i haven't
been an m anything and the this is what
happens with me and wait is like i get
overweight and then i do something
extreme to get underweight and then i
get to underweight but i'm really
unhappy because i'm not satiated and my
body's going to feed me
don't feed me feed me and i'm like i
look wicked and close for that two
seconds
two seconds that that happens the minute
you stop being abusive to yourself by
you know not giving yourself nutrients
and food you instant so i'm like yo-yo
yo-yo
cause yeah you're not even yo-yo but
you're watching the yo-yo go so it's
like you're like
judging yourself at every different
every yeah every fluctuation of it like
being alive is [ __ ] tricky
life is fun
who has that joke it's so good no norm
mcdonald he's telling joking people like
people are always like man i can't
believe it so and so killed themselves
and he's like you can't
have you ever been alive
[Laughter]
by the way when norm passed away i just
spent
every waking hour listening to old
interviews yeah listening to stand-up
sets
just like i i there's a there's a
channel on youtube right it's like not
normal whatever um
but
he's just the best he's great absolutely
unique unique he's very his british
sense of humor kind of do you think that
it'd
cater to i feel like would love it
yeah sort of outside uh
uh is it british yeah because it's so
dry
dry yeah maybe that's the aspect of it
jimmy dore i really like
listening he just had a an oh uh
no who else am i thinking of
um who's a british community just had a
special come out on netflix jimmy carter
jimmy carr yeah yeah and jimmy dore i
like but jimmy carr is a really nice guy
you guys look a little bit alike you've
already seen jimmy yeah he's a he's a
mate of mine we do look a bit alike a
little bit yeah i think we've got the
same plastic soon
[Laughter]
give me the jimmy give me the lobby the
full jimmy yeah let's get one more
question and we'll get you guys out of
here man i appreciate your time today
what else we got here kyle
what's up boys
i have a question for robbie if you
don't mind robbie some of your biggest
gigs
arguably have been in australia down
under yeah
i've seen one in melbourne it was
massive
unbelievable we went with my mum and dad
absolutely
massive what do you love about australia
robbie
theo i know you've been to australia as
well oh yeah anything you love as well
mate
gang gang boys from melbourne australia
gang
is a bit of anxiety right so i was
watching i i'm a fan of yours and watch
podcasts and always dip into your world
to see what you're up to and uh there
was a nick swanson nick's that's his
name oh yeah his the the podcast that
you did with him and then there was the
questions at the end and i was like
no one likes me who's going to ask me oh
you thought let's go to a question
there's none there yeah yeah let's go to
the question there's just gonna be
somebody abusing me
yeah what an [ __ ]
what have you got him on i didn't even
know where he was going with that
question either yeah we had a bunch do
you know what i absolutely
here's a question for you right it is my
answer my answer is
if you could be born a different
nationality
well you have to you have to choose one
okay mine would be australian i would
choose to be an australian because i
just absolutely love aussies i
absolutely adore australia it's like
if i had to come from australia
i probably have a different relationship
with it like in australia in england i'm
not allowed to be me i'm not allowed you
know tall puppy syndrome
kill their own let's you know build them
up and then kill them and then keep
killing them until they're dead 70 times
but in australia they just allow me to
be me and my sense of humor and they
don't misquote me and they you know
and it's like
australia is like england but without
the [ __ ] oh and i i just adore being
there because i just feel as i can
exhale you know it's like i feel as i
can let the stomachs just go
oh
god i can be that
so my answer to the question that i
posed if you could be born again and had
to choose different nationality who
would it be australia wow
australia i go maybe i love australia
too man i love what i love about it is
just like the energy over there people
are excited people are willing to risk
their lives every day for nothing you
know yeah they'll die for nothing dog
you know what i'm saying it's like yeah
that's [ __ ] it's just a bunch of
human red bull cans you know they're
just willing to do whatever
nothing's off limits there they just and
they're just real like loving and
[ __ ] outgoing they'll [ __ ] love
you so much they'll [ __ ] kill you
yeah
they're just really really fired up man
they'll jump off of something and die
you know just to give you a note you
know
so
yeah i love australia man i would
probably go i would go australian i'd
even maybe go dark australia and maybe
like a little mix maybe white [ __ ] or
something go like
grilled australian you know just to have
a little bit of that darker ambiance but
also still be australian you know a
little bit more bush
uh but still whack you know
still a whack i'd go french oh yeah [ __ ]
it just to be a complete god to lean
into me oh yeah and i could speak like
no what do you do
[Laughter]
my kids my kids speak french oh my god
my kids are fluent really
how did it happen
my wife's a francophile which means she
thinks she's french she's from she's
from coldwater canyon but like she
thinks she's french so she my wife
speaks french italian
and turkish
and and my kids now
have conversations in full
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah it's uh
it's super annoying oh if my kids were
sitting around speaking in french
looking up at me and laughing i forget
it
and you're like what are you saying
about me nothing daddy i love you you're
like you also just did an impersonation
of every character from waterboy too
yeah so i think i mean that's insane
though man to have french speakers in
your own home and you don't know what's
going on dude that's
like my son charlie's six and we were in
switzerland just recently and i took him
out on his scooter
and there was a lady we call them
lollipop ladies
the people that pedestrians probably no
no no the ladies that helped all the men
that helped kids get across the
pedestrians oh traffic guards yeah yeah
yeah and traffic guards and she's like
she looks at me she goes
because
i don't
have vinegarette yeah
and then charlie my six-year-old goes
uh the lady says that there is a race in
town and there's going to be lots of
people coming through on bikes and it's
going to be really dangerous uh you
better go across the road now
really i was just like
charlie's taking care of you yeah yeah
you're getting lit around by the
six-year-old charlie
that's a cool name for a kid i like it
oh charlton oh that's a risk
why but charlton just sounds like cause
i think it's a candy also in america in
charltons oh it used to be a dance
actually the charlton didn't that's the
charleston oh it's all stunned yeah
closed up
so definitely you could see him doing
some dancing i've got i've got a got a
charlton a bow
a coco and a teddy oh man teddy's
theodore right yeah theodore theodora
yeah yeah good name where does ball come
from
uh
i don't
oh yeah how's that spelled
b-o yeah yeah but that's how i wanted
both oh yeah because of the jigsaw
yeah i did yeah but like in your head
you're like be all yeah
one of my good mates from growing up was
named beau actually and he yeah bo's a
popular name in louisiana yeah i think i
think it's a rednecky name right oh let
me think it can be but it also is kind
of like an affluent name
so i think it depends on how you spell
it b.o is probably a little bit more
rural right and then b-e-a-u is a little
bit more like uh
uh
french french yeah yeah beauregard yeah
i don't want a boat to be called
beauregard that's a good name no it's
[ __ ]
beauregard no it's not beauregard
yeah but still dude
you need to be from uh east sussex is
that a place
it sounds like one yeah
what about that okay is is i say is a
question for you right anxiety how's
your anxiety been during because we're
wearing to the end now aren't we yeah
yes so how's your anxiety been through
this podcast um mine's been good until
you asked me a question
[Laughter]
you've just been you've just been the
audience yeah yeah popping in you've
done a great job of being that mark's
very supportive i will say it's one
really i mean he has a lot of great
characteristics one of them is that he's
very supportive he's a good committee
you can't understand what he's saying
you know what i'm saying so it's almost
trickery because he can be like i'm
great at this and then you just don't
know what he's talking about my new
thing is to explain the joke to the
audience
all right this is why some of you didn't
laugh let me you don't see it
do you do you worry about that being in
america and trying to being successful
in the career that you're choosing to be
but in a place where they can't
understand you yeah i'm just trying to
figure out who to navigate it yeah do
you clip your words so that people
yeah sometimes like instead of like if i
say the path
i have to be like oh i was on the
sidewalk
yeah but not it's it's not you know like
the bonnet boot it's not all of that
it's your accent yeah oh yeah yeah
definitely i'll be like i even but if i
call it out if i say like
i went to the bear yeah and then people
are like he went to the bear
and i'm like oh i went to the bar
so people know you're at the bar but
like
yeah but like if you're road testing
material yeah and you're like that
didn't work it's like do you know if it
didn't work because they just didn't
yeah yeah yeah that's what i have to
figure it out i'm like oh if i even say
like the stare like she had stairs in
her feeling on her ceiling
she had stairs on her feeling that's a
rash mark
but i was like why do they knock it and
i i figured out then they think i'm
saying she had stairs on her feelings on
her ceiling right right so i'd be like
oh no stars like
twinkle yeah i just have to explain it a
bit more
i have to treat the audience like
they're dumb
yeah do you know what that means
[Laughter]
we're getting dumb here dude america
we're getting dumb fast man uh there was
one more interesting thing i was going
to ask you but i think i almost forgot
what it was
no i don't get too much anxiety around
you uh you see you're very welcoming i
think you have a very welcoming and
inviting personality you ask a lot of
questions and so i think it uh yeah i
don't feel a ton of anxiety around you
do you um when you do podcasts do you
revise the night before or do you just
rock up and and hit it sometimes i
revive you know when i talk with mark
about you coming in like you know i know
about your career but i didn't know like
what your energy was like really um but
mark you know
just said you're basically just a pretty
normal guy to be around and that it's
engaging conversation and so i didn't
think too far past that uh we got some
questions from folks
and then yeah i just like to kind of see
what's going on with the day but if we
had an author come in then we like we
had an author come in the other day and
so with him we
you know went through and read like half
the book as much as i could do you think
joe rogan
sort of just rocks up these days or do
you think that he puts in a bit of
i think it's a mix i think joe rogan and
this is something i learned about him
recently was that he always was very
people would say he talked too much he
said he said people when i was younger
would say man you talk too much you know
and then look what he did with he like
is extremely curious
so he has i think a very curious nature
so curiosity i think if you have it
inside of you it makes your brain it
like gives your face questions all the
time to get to ask someone so if your
curiosity is really working
i think my curiosity works better when
i'm feeling good when i'm not like in a
space of self very much where my brain
isn't kind of worrying about things in
my own world so i think the healthier i
am mentally and stuff the more curiosity
i have and the better i do
but what do i think joe does i think at
this point he probably has enough
comfort with how to do certain things he
knows the mechanism yeah do you um when
you
when you're doing podcasts do you
find that you are
insanely concentrating
do you like for example when i'm doing a
podcast whether i
i did one interview where i was asking
the questions but the rest of the time
i'm on podcasts i am just hyper focused
wow are you hyper focused in these
moments or i was watching you do the
nick thing the nick swanson thing and it
was just like i was just chatting the
[ __ ] between two people it felt very
natural it felt very comfortable yeah
cause i i if i'm if this is on and i'm
here i am just like like i've taken
seven adderall
let me think i guess i do feel more
focused than usual it's kind of a
respite from the rest of my day so i'm
grateful that i have to think about
other people and you know just be
involved with others so that's nice but
do i feel hyper focused i think it
depends um
i know that people like when people are
just having a conversation when it
doesn't feel sometimes like there's a
ton of planning
i find so
and what does the rest of your day look
like the rest of my day looks like i'll
probably patch up with these guys and
make sure everything's good look at some
social media clips and stuff like that
um
i gotta
check in with a sponsor
so i had a little bit of a falling out
with a sponsor so i need to check in
with him and decide what i'm going to do
are you a meds
no i've been off for like about
two months but it's also scary because i
feel like i had uh
because i got on them like 15 years ago
so it's like why are you welcome i think
because i just had i felt like i wasn't
having a lot of feelings so i'm like is
one of the reasons i'm not having
feelings because i'm on
these meds like part of me i was
thinking sometimes like it's hard for me
to like i feel like if i want to like
fall in love with somebody
so i was like maybe i'm not maybe i'm
not maybe i'm feeling not feeling loved
because i don't and how do you feel
about that being two months off from now
i feel like i have a lot of like i've
been kind of like
a little bit more tearful honestly dude
a little bit more emotional yeah yeah so
that's been a little bit
kind of almost a little bit alarming but
then part of me is like maybe there's
these feelings that they've been needing
to get out for so long and they haven't
so i just don't know
for me and i am not yeah obviously we're
not doctors we're not doctors and i'm
not saying i'm not we've never had a
doctor in here mark's a doctor
i'm not suggesting anybody do what i'm
doing at all it's not what i'm saying
just how this is working for me i'm on
[ __ ] meds and that's the way
it's going to stay wow that's it i am
totally in i don't need to go and
evaluate see if there's some feelings
that need come and coming out
as i i i spent
i would say 1990
to
[Music]
in abject misery of some form or another
because of my poor mental health
and i don't want to waste another second
in there yeah yeah that makes sense you
know and that's that's for me you know
it's like i'm in
the relationship with my misses
i've got the kids
uh
for me it makes total sense just to be
like okay this is my life this is what i
need for it to happen
uh this is what i'm doing wow i think
about that too i think about getting
back on actually i yesterday was the
first time what were you um just on
sertraline or something generic prozac i
think fluoxetines what what what
milligram pretty low dose like 10 yeah
maybe 15. okay it's nothingness
yeah
and and have you not had the zaps
the the coming off them how did you wean
off them
uh i weaned uh pretty decently like
cutting down pills getting the smallest
pills and then cutting them in half and
stuff like that
no i haven't had anything like that i've
just been more emotional i noticed like
i'll start talking to somebody and then
i'm balling up and they're like sir this
is a carl's jr
[Laughter]
you know
we're closed like sorry mate but that
but that happens with me is like i
all of a sudden i hope
so uh we'll just
yeah and my wife will be like boozy and
i'll be like
really yeah but what i've done is is
forgotten to take my meds for six days
oh
but but i but i don't know that i've
forgotten to take my meds until and and
every time it happens i forget that
that's why i'm crying
and it happens twice a year
where i'll just be like
[Laughter]
and my wife would be like because like
they she she responds so much better to
tears than anger
oh yeah
yeah it's like i am angry about your
time keeping and she'll be like and then
like i get in trouble for being angry
about her time keeping but if i would i
don't know what to do
time-keeping she'd be like i try to make
it
but it's the weirdest thing with the
meds where i just
forget to take them occasionally and
then i make the solemn swear that i will
never forget to take them ever again
because it's really bad and then i'll
just forget do you ever feel that like
if you take the meds you're giving it
like there's just some like big pharmacy
system you're giving in to i don't know
if i feel that way oh i kind of i've
never taken meds and never cry so
opposite the boat
no but i just wonder why would god put
us together where we don't or you know
why would the why would we be put
together where we need some other thing
you know it seems like we would be okay
but maybe also having meds could be just
a side effect of where we are as a
population and species in time like that
one we're way different than what things
used to be like yeah
you know the the past is a
it's a different country they do things
differently there that's a great
statement the past is a different
country yeah it's it's all sorts of
change that's why you know everybody's
freaking mentally ill now is because
of what society is doing to itself and
if i can just have like a breather if i
can have something that gives me a
breather from myself
i'm good with that i'm good with that
it's kind of like why would you get a
haircut of god didn't want you to yeah
why would you put on clouds yeah so like
it's kind of like giving in to
balenciaga
those cheap shoes
oh that's a great joke
maybe we'll finish there
ah can i ask about your teeth before you
go yeah are they yours yeah well done
thanks man oh wait actually these two
are fake
yes
yeah yeah yeah you got good teeth but
you got good white teeth mine is getting
a little beiged out no yours are he's
got american teeth doesn't it i gotta
shine up such really amazing teeth yeah
yeah wow when i was young i had spaced
out teeth you know and then you did you
have a retainer yeah i got the retainers
yeah sometimes i wish i could go back
but it's all good i'm gonna i want teeth
like i'm gonna go and get some teeth
in a bit yeah okay
yeah yeah
you kind of i feel like you have that
kind of like andy dufresne like runs a
train like like you're like a train
conductor kind of vibe
you have that you don't want those
bright white teeth that people get in
like zimbabwe or something oh no no i
don't wanna i don't want a mouth full of
teeth like that i want yours yeah oh you
can yeah but you you look as though you
you've got
you've got a mouth full of teeth they
don't look like yours yeah yeah really
what is it what is it right
economic background when you're growing
up not great right yeah yeah not good
shitty yeah [ __ ] what what is it about
your economic background growing up
shitty teeth amazing yeah my economic
background growing up shitty teeth
brown and bitty
what happens what's the psyche with
america and the psyche with the uk and
ireland where we're just like [ __ ] teeth
maybe in america they think everyone can
be a movie star
do that's what it is well they cuz you
could possibly can yeah like i i just
don't think they ca like teeth are down
the line yeah like haircut nails yeah
that means past liver for you
well
i think generally like i also noticed
like if you do like a lot of uh
i i thought when i was in
in la or in united kingdom or britain
that they had more
a lot of the uh
women the men were better looking than
the women i felt like
that makes sense i thought that and you
know it could have just i didn't see a
ton of couples i probably only saw about
80 couples
you know and a lot of
lonesome men which is my audience
but
which i'm grateful for guys
uh
but i i felt like maybe the women was
more you see a lot more tanned women as
well like the fancy women in england is
real tanned up and perfect yeah it's
like a popular thing you know they were
on sheets that's one thing when you
arrive in los angeles just the amount of
good-looking women is just
on yeah believable i know we touched on
it before but it's i i remember
like getting here and i was just like
on a sidewalk
at the the lights and i just thought i'm
going to count
every fit woman in the car i was like 23
at the time i'm going to count
i'm going to count 50 see how many fit
women they're all oh yeah they're off
i'm just like one two three
it was it was like the ratio was 50 to
50. really yeah yeah yeah yeah it's the
fit to none
it is unreal here yeah that's true
people are just at least fit they're
like a
they fit well yeah everybody's yeah
people could do a medium here and
they're okay
um do you think that uh
oh [ __ ]
i don't know
it was good though oh did you ever hire
one of those dayton services if you got
some money to help you find a decent
lady
because i wonder if when you're popular
at your level of fame how do you
seed out you know like
i didn't want to be in a relationship so
no but i i would have done if it would
have carried on for longer you know i
met ida when i was 32 i'm now 47.
yeah yeah you look great for 47 maybe
well thank you very much yeah i like
that yeah so um
i i probably would have done eventually
uh but at the point at that point in
time i didn't want to be in a
relationship so no i didn't
imagine you won tinder
like breyer in it
yeah it's awful is it why is it awful
because you just like you match and you
talk and then it stops it's very like
why does it imagine talking a lot
because there's bigger better offer
there always is on that side all right
it's like it's shaq is on there i heard
yeah like
all these famous people yeah so if
you're not diplo yeah yeah if you if
you're not deployed you're not getting
the look into it is that what you get an
initial look in but then the match with
someone else yeah it'll look out yeah
the conversation is very how's it going
not too bad and you done
what are you are you on those things i'm
not on i think about it sometimes but
i'm trying to go the other way right now
i got to get a little bit of space
but
i just don't need to be doing anything
like
because i'm just feeling compulsive
about it that's what that's what i'm
overall working on is just compulsivity
find someone you really like yeah
then don't be a [ __ ]
and that's a that's a possibility too i
want to leave that door open
that's all you've got to do the second
part
yeah but then you know i don't know i
think it i also think there's a time in
your life where you get to where you're
ready to do that and i think it's part
of me feels myself getting there a
little bit
really [ __ ] yeah that's what it is
yeah that's what i was saying the whole
time it's like i wasn't ready at 32
apparently i was because i have been
since i've been 32. it's like you are
ready now yeah you know you just don't
know it
finds you know if she comes in and she
makes you laugh and you trust her
and you like looking at her
marry it
[Laughter]
marry marry it and then like i say i'll
swear again don't be a [ __ ] and then you
win yeah now i i when you were saying
that i got a bit anxious
yeah the marriott no the whole like it's
that easy those three things oh yeah i
got anxious i was like oh but what if
there's another girl
oh yeah
who's also
but that's gonna happen that but that's
gonna happen always for the rest of your
life yes but then i'll be like you wait
here i'll be right back
that happens with me when i'm watching
the television and like ah she's
uh oh yeah this happens all of this and
then i go oh yeah this happens all of
the time because it's like that thing
inside me and then you know it's like i
i have an amazing wife who's
fit and great to look at makes me laugh
and i trust her and like what am i you
know what am i what would i be swapping
for yeah what what would be better about
any of these other people but here i'll
swap for the possibility
so that's something then so you got to
look at yeah what is like what yeah what
would you swap for sometimes you never
make a list of the values and the one
thing that you have and so there's
always like that's what i noticed too if
i don't ever really kind of make a list
of what like oh well with this i have
like
always have a friend you got like a
teammate a freaking somebody to watch do
things with like if you never really
list that out then you'll just always
think there's this invisible idea of
something over here that's better that's
what i noticed i have this invisible
idea that i've never even looked at like
what is this idea yeah yeah yeah you
know it's just a [ __ ] and then you
get over there and it's just some
[ __ ] lady's smoking outside of a
building
a bleak morpheus just blob of an idea
it's like the sort of grayish with
tinges of blackening you sort of like i
don't know what it is but it's better
yes that's what it is yeah
it's always going to be out there man um
thank you for your time today guys yep
robbie uh mark it was a pleasure man
yeah thank you thank you for having us
[Music]
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel
but it's it take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
find a song
[Music]